[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
all right so we got episode episode 498
we got the full crew today we got a lot
to cover yesterday's uh stock market
Tyler if you can show it real quick what
happened we gotta talk about this this
is Wall Street Journal thou Falls more
than 600 points as crypto selloff and
Midterm results Loom the reason for a
lot of this markets being down 6 30
yesterday's uncertainty uh it doesn't
look like a lot of people are happy with
the results they thought it was going to
be a red wave it wasn't the day after we
found out how do people react to the
market by the way in the morning
yesterday if you think about a Wednesday
stock market was up that was up 300 ends
up down 6 30. this FTX situation from 32
billion to 16 billion guy loses 94 of
his wealth and they may not even be able
to finance the entire thing they may go
to zero crypto took a hit bitcoin's down
3 000 yesterday not a good day we got a
lot of things to cover we got Ricky in
the house we got Tom Ellsworth in the
house hello hello we got
in the house Mr Siri and Vinnie and we
got our Frontier uh Adam sosnik do you
have a middle name or no curious yeah
what is your middle I'm gonna bring it
out there
isn't it like one of those Stacy like
Adam Stacy uh sauce
that's what happens when you spend too
much
and then Dave Rubin is on his way we got
a lot of topics
sounds good if you're listening Dave
we're starting we'll see you shortly
drive safe um
a lot of layoffs not just the one from
Zuck eleven thousand Tom's got an update
for us for a bunch of different things
that's going on with Redfin mortgage
real estate uh some news today about
Amazon which very interesting how much
of a valuation Amazon lost did you see
the number they lost nearly a trillion
dollars of valuation Amazon lost 870 880
evaluation they lost one and a half
trillion dollars of equity has been lost
in America since May last five months
we'll cover that uh Elon Musk we talked
about this to you I'm a year and a half
ago Twitter did a tweet I don't know if
you guys remember this or not people can
permanently have Twitter work from home
Elon Musk said nope no more days you
gotta come home you gotta work you got
to come to the office you got to work
from office and obviously that's how
it's always been but elon's bringing it
back excited to talk about that topic
there Adidas are saying they're going to
make Yeezys with or without Kanye we're
gonna see if that's going to do well or
not Connie is right now shopping to see
if someone's gonna do anything you ready
folks do you know how much money was
spent at midterms do know the number
16.7 billion dollars was spent on this
midterm the biggest ever in the history
of Elections and we got a bunch of other
things to talk about before before we do
that let's go to our sponsors uh sponsor
today
is private internet access and the
company's name is called private
internet access and we've been talking
about this for some time you've been
hearing me talk about private uh you
know cyber security for a long time we
talk a lot about Aura because what Aura
does is check to see if your passwords
are being used and many of you have
taken advantage of and I'm getting a lot
of you know updates news on what's
happened with yours but this is
completely separate I'm at the airport
I'm at the airport on about to get on a
flight guy next to me says are you using
this do you have VPN what VPN I said
nothing he said let me show you
something he gets onto my service on my
computer he says you are fully free
right now somebody wanted to find out
what you're doing they can get through
it because you're not protected you need
to get yourself a VPN this is the first
time where a guy who wasn't selling me
anything he just said you got to get a
VPN he was a value chainer so if we got
to get a VPN we got to team up with a
VPN and this is the VPN that's
sponsoring the show right now uh so you
know these types of attacks have
increased 107 over last year it's
costing people billions of dollars every
year and private internet access is one
of the best products in the world and
the best VPN for the US with 50 servers
and 50 states in the US no other VPN has
uh this amount of service in the US so
start protecting yourself and your data
they have over 30 million users and a
4.6 start on trust pilot with 8 000
reviews so you can feel confident that
you're using the best in the marketplace
having said that you can go to
piavpn.com forward slash pbd once again
Pia vpn.com forward slash pbdpia stands
for private internet access Pia
vpn.com forward slash pbd right now Pi
is having a massive Black Friday sale
for our customers 83 percent off with
four months for free it's only two
dollars and three cents a month go take
advantage of this protect yourself
having said that let's get into it okay
so Tom economy Zuck lays off 11 000
Redfin I'm gonna go straight to what's
going on with um
page four uh Redfin shuts home flipping
business lays off 13 of Staff in
slumping housing market this is a Wall
Street Journal story they let off 13 of
its staff on Wednesday and close its
home flipping unit saying the operation
was too expensive and too risky to
continue the seattle-based company which
operates a real estate brokerage at home
listing websites said the decisions were
made because it's it is predicting that
the real estate market is going to be
smaller next year they're not even
talking about 2022 2023 smaller next
year and its home flipping business is
losing money it previously laid off
eight percent of its Workforce in June
of this year the closure of redfin's
Home flipping business Redfin now
follows Open Door Technologies Inc
posting record losses last week the
biggest home flipping company sold too
many homes for less than their purchase
price Tom what is going on here give us
an update on the market and layoffs well
first of all redfin's just the beginning
on the real estate side you're going to
see Zillow you're going to see others
that are in real estate they're going to
be making adjustments and and the ones
that made it easy for you to watch an
internet seminar and buy real estate you
too can be a flipper all those folks
watching those seminars on YouTube you
know and some of them are good
educational about real estate but others
we know they're scam artists well those
folks are the ones that go into Redfin
and going to Zillow trying to start
their home flipping business and the
real estate market is just not there I
think that's only part of the story
because interest rates and layoffs are
coming that sector it's beyond
Zuckerberg the rumor before the election
was a thousand people would be laid off
and many people including me this is at
Facebook yeah Facebook meta they said
from a thousand to and then they did
eleven thousand that's correct the leak
that was out before the election they
believe was inside an intentional news
leak to kind of soften the blow and then
they laid off eleven thousand although
Facebook was up in after hours trading
just as coach because what is the market
like admissions of errors and then
reduction of cost and so there the other
thing that really surprised me is stripe
because you know stripe is huge they're
bigger than American Express by value
and they're laying off 15 of their
Workforce and I'm going to read you
something this was I think good
leadership and valuetainment we're out
there talking leadership and helping
people grow their companies and giving
them examples of how to do it here's a
way to be honest with your people so
this is the leadership at stripe laying
off 15 in making these head count
changes
team stripe might reasonably wonder
whether Stripes leadership made some
errors of judgment
well we'll go further than that in our
view we made two very consequential
mistakes not just errors of judgment and
we want to highlight them here we were
too optimistic about the near-term
growth in 2022-23 and we grew our
operating costs too quickly we have to
correct these and that's leadership
coming forward and just saying hey you
know I thought there was a party going
on in the economy I grew too quick too
much but this is just the beginning
Stripes layoffs Redfin layoffs
zillows reportedly coming and then meta
laying off more than they thought this
is just the beginning this is the
economic correction that we've been
talking about makes sense by the way we
got the the great Dave Rubin here if we
can open up the volume and let them in
but go ahead you were saying
um well essentially what I think is
happening is you talked about how it's
been fake like everything that's
happened over the last couple years has
been fake printing money and how money
flows to the top right
if you look at all these major asset
classes whether it's the Dow whether
it's s p the NASDAQ Bitcoin ethereum the
list goes on and on and on basically
what's happening is just it's reverting
to where it was back in 2020 March of
2020. now there's you can give us some
case examples like apple is up huge like
way above where it is 2020 and that has
not reverted but then you have companies
like Facebook that have done the exact
opposite it's almost an inverted
situation but
all everything you talk about being fake
there he is baby everything you talk
about printing money being fake this is
all basically what's happening right now
no and and and it's great to see who was
really having a lot of fake success
success and the man that just came in
here he's definitely having a lot of
real real
good to have you on oh it's fantastic to
have Davon here uh but by the way while
to stay on the story before we wrap it
up and I'm going to go straight to
Dave's commentary and thoughts on what
happened uh uh yesterday so Greg uh Cher
whom I had dinner with last night he was
at the office here he uh we were talking
about FTX yeah so FTX goes from a 32
billion dollar company to 16 billion
dollar company to binance says yeah
we'll give you a billion dollars to help
you bail yourself out and then they
change their minds and they said no
we're not giving you the billion dollars
and so this is a company that could
potentially go from 32 billion to 16b
billion to zero in no time and the
founder gave 39 million dollars to
democratic super Pacs and one of the
other Executives that owns a lot of
shares in the company gave 19 million
dollars to Republican super Pacs that's
Ryan salami that gave a 19 million
dollars great last name so this is
what's taking place with this company
Venture funds invested around two
billion dollars into the company most
recently added 32 billion dollar
valuation without a single board seat in
return did you hear what I just said Tom
2 billion 32 billion evaluation with
zero board seats in return and these are
not lame people that don't know how to
negotiate board seats in fact it's
unclear if FTX even has a board of
directors audit committee CFO Chief
compliance officer instead it just seems
to have a some sort of VC advisory
committee here's who was involved FTX
backers include Sequoia which once sued
binance for unrelated reasons
time SoftBank tiger Global Bond
BlackRock Lightspeed Insight Partners
rivet Capital race Capital all of these
guys invested in the point of this
article is saying that at the very least
the fdaq experience will put a major
Chill on Venture investments in crypto
even in unaffected areas like
decentralized Finance if FTX can go from
32 billion to zero maybe in just 36
hours who's to say the same can't happen
elsewhere why would LPS take the chance
this is a very very legit big hit to the
crypto Community think about this so
32 billion valuation I give you a
billion dollars investment now you're
worth 33 billion dollars because you got
my cash
I only own 133rd
you think of it that way and so
if I want to Triple my money that
thing's got to be worth a hundred
billion dollars someday and so there was
apparently feelings that there is more
than just frothiness in the mod in the
market you know what I mean this was a
this was a root beer shaken up and then
you open it in a crowded room I mean
this is huge all over your face now oh
yeah all over everything but think about
that Pat because you make investments
bad visual for Tom but go ahead
don't get distracted stay focused
because it's Adam's distracting yeah I
know but think about that yeah you make
angel Investments and you make more than
Angel investment serious Investments
would you invest in something where
you've got one Thirty third of it that's
an insight and a tripling just to Triple
your money or double your money the
things got to be worth 66 billion
dollars that's that's when you know
that's when you know when when people
are trying to be that greedy that late
last year at Super Bowl the whole Super
Bowl was about crypto yeah all you have
to say is who won the Super Bowl last
year Chris crypto I don't know who won
the Super Bowl LA Rams I can tell you
crypto one and you know by the way FTX
Tom Brady's a part of it Jose's a part
of it you know how many celebrities are
a part of it left and right people were
involved in this uh but uh but that's a
whole different conversation on what's
taking place I know a lot of guys that
are on the crypto Community who's they
put 95 percent of their Savings in it
like I'm talking 95 of their Savings in
it and they're doing Uber right now late
at night because Pat you're not supposed
to bring it up I didn't want to do it
but sorry but listen props to your 4.9
star Don Uber thank you you got to be
proud
listen at least I'm gonna give you the
shout out I have candy and cologne so
Dave Rubin tell us how you feeling man
I'm feeling all right first off I got to
apologize for being late because I was
told there's a hurricane to come in or a
bruin or something and uh I was sleeping
as the car arrived you guys sent the car
you're a professional yeah and I was
sleeping and my phone's blowing up Dave
you got to get in the car but I thought
the whole East Coast was going to be
blown apart so anyway I'm a little late
can I give you some friendly advice
because you've been in Florida less than
a year bro right less than a year we've
been trying to play basketball we've
been trying to you know your knee your
kid everything he's back yeah as someone
born and raised in Miami this is use
this for the rest of the time you're in
Florida unless it's a hurricane cat
three or higher just carry on my friend
okay keep calling and carry on tropical
storm tropical depression I don't know
what's going on take a pill and keep it
moves it's a beautiful day out there
exactly I am I'm happy here well we're
glad to have you here man yeah we're
really glad to have you been realizing
last time I came you were in like a five
thousand dollar sharp suit as you often
are and I was in like a ratty ass shirt
so I thought all right I'll get in my
usual operation today by the way first
of all everybody's got a suit on except
me today
everybody's got a suit up
I try to switch it up today and I asked
everybody yesterday be unpredictable I
mixed it up today so where's your suit
he goes I want to show my tats but but
he he looks like the CEO with the
three-piece suit on
[Music]
everybody's watching everybody's seeing
what's going to happen you're seeing
different names you're seeing different
you know centered races house how did
you think that they went well first let
me just say as we were all here in
Florida everyone here lives in Florida I
take it California call me foreign
outdoor Frankie Valley concert okay
there you go over there
um well look as a Floridian as a new
Floridian as you said I'm here I got
here on December 17th 2021 I will never
forget the day and the moment that I
landed here uh you know Florida is so
set up so everything here is right this
is what America is supposed to be this
is what competent governance is this is
what Freedom's all about we are set up
so well here and this will continue and
and I tweeted out yesterday Lee zeldin
who just did something incredible in New
York despite losing move down here let's
take all the confident people I I mean
it I really mean it let's just how about
we just open this place up for all of
the competent people let's get all of
the competent workers all of the
competent thinkers and money managers
and everybody we've got land here you
know we have a housing problem here but
there's plenty of land down in Homestead
and across the Panhandle there's land
let's start building do some great
infrastructure things so I'm feeling
great about Florida the rest of the
night
I mean we still don't know what's up
with Arizona so it's a little kind of
wishy-washy but it certainly didn't go
the way that I think it would have been
best for America for a free America
let's put it that way but by the way you
know zeldin you know the status first
time I think in two decades or it was a
four decades that a governor race was
that closest the closest race in four
decades to lose by only five points you
got to give him respect and nobody knew
him two months ago nobody had a clue who
this guy was some people thought he was
like a you know what do you call it one
of these heavy metal guys
keep rocking yeah but uh uh so so okay
so now the question the main question
everyone's asking and you know you've
been asked this you know yourself and
you know so look the reason why this
happened is because what America doesn't
want is anybody that uh Trump endures
is you know it's not looking good it's
because of his involvement and the
stories coming out he blamed his wife
you know these articles that are right
and saying he was losing his mind
yesterday you know he was livid he was
screaming obviously that's an Insider
story but even New York Post posted
something today talking about maybe it's
time to move because what America is
showing is Florida the guy won 62 out of
67 counties it's a lot 62 out of 67
counties and the five that he lost by
the way all had record numbers for
Republicans so Broward I think was up by
12 points for Republicans lost he won in
a certain sense yeah so so what do you
what do you think about that do you
think do you think it's at it's a point
where you know it's time to move on or
it's not going to happen you have to
know that he's going to be running and
there's got to be a strategy and he is
going to call him out and it's not going
to be pretty and DeSantis should still
run and they got to go through it and
let the Republicans decide who they want
as a candidate what do you think I think
just before we get into the Trump thing
specifically I think we just have to
accept that probably 40 of the country
just wants more nonsense they want more
government they want more lockdowns they
want more control over their lives they
want higher taxes they want bad
governance and bad schools they they
have been so brainwashed you know the
NPC means the non-playable character
character meme they want it and it just
is and we can do the best we can to to
bring better ideas to them and break
some of them but I think we just have to
accept that that that's sort of separate
then did Trump really move this thing I
don't really think this thing was about
Trump I mean the Trump the real Trump
people did not do that well I mean the
fact that Oz lost to fetterman I mean
because I mean Penman is whacked out but
fetterman can't speak right he literally
not only does he have all the worst
ideas like all of the worst socialist
big government ideas and release people
out on this you know the criminals back
into the streets and all that but the
guy cannot speak and then did you see
last night on MSNBC they actually had a
panel on whether John fetterman should
be the nominee for president in 2024. it
is a televised mental institution over
there yeah yeah that he should be the
one that he should be the nominee that
he should run yeah but like how do you
how does Oz Lose to that guy like
there's something there other than like
they all just want lockdowns they're all
idiots what Acts actually happen though
like go deeper into the fact of like how
does Oz a very well-known character lose
to a literal Weekend at Bernie's
character yeah he wasn't look I I
actually kind of like Dr Oz and I think
he's sort of I think he's kind of like
you Adam I think he's kind of like a
disaffected liberal who's woken up a
little bit and he's kind of he's kind of
getting there I was here what about what
it's about eight months so I got to see
how far we've dragged you because I
dragged I dragged Mar I did two hours
with Mark exactly so I watched the whole
thing I want to talk about that for sure
um but Oz just wasn't a great a great
candidate but but it's a moot point that
anyone in their right mind voted for
fetterman that you thought this is a guy
we should send to the Senate he can't
speak you know what I mean that's not to
diminish the stroke and all that but
like come on it has to be better than
this we're sending the guy in the hoodie
who can't speak let's roll uh so there
we have so but anyway to the Trump thing
that you asked originally
DeSantis is the future of free America
and Trump has to figure out if he wants
to fit in that or not yes does Trump
have the power to burn the whole thing
down right now and Destroy DeSantis
probably could he figure out a way to do
it and just split the party and just
create endless chaos yeah I voted for
Trump the second time I've met him I've
liked him I I've interviewed him he's
got to figure this thing out now in in a
decent way uh and I I don't know if he
has it in him but you can feel it people
are people are starting to turn now you
don't think he has it in him to realize
that it's the Santa so you don't think
he has it in him to make another run you
don't think he has nothing in him to the
form be a unifier for the Republican
Party does he have it in him to be he
could be the king maker imagine if
instead of next week instead of what
everyone thinks is going to happen which
is that he announces that he's running
imagine if he gets up there and he says
you know I've looked at the lay of the
land I've been doing this for a long
time I'm of a certain age DeSantis he's
the guy he's the guy and let me help
what a great and not not even an ending
but what a beautiful next chapter of the
Trump story I'll get out there I'll do
rallies I'll fight for the it's all
you're I can already see it
yeah but I mean that's a great that's a
great that's a hopeful Wishful thing but
as a New Yorker as somebody with his ego
I wish I wish I agree
but I love it but maybe we gotta maybe
we gotta pump the hell out of that story
so he hears it because if Trump is one
thing he does hear what people want you
know and if the story is man you can
still be loved you can be loved and
accomplish some of the things that you
wanted to accomplish but getting through
the machine again and that you're gonna
have to take out this I mean that the
sanctimonious line a couple days ago
yeah why who sanctimonious did you look
up the definition of sanctimonious I
looked it up yeah and it's basically
like
okay and then I like Trump this is not
show the definition of what's saying
yeah it's kind of by the way because
when he comes up with crooked Hillary or
you know whacking crazy Nancy sleepy Joe
sleep it's not off the cuff yeah I mean
a lot of the stuff that he does is
certainly off the cup don't no doubt but
this is well thought out all right we're
going with sleepy Joe sanctimonious
making a show of being morally Superior
to other people so he's like I could say
anything I want about Ron the scam to
whatever name you want to go he's like I
want to call him you're not holier than
thou it's okay you're not chosen by God
buddy he picked that on purpose so in my
in my opinion give me one example one
example ever in Trump's life where he's
like I will take a back seat you be the
leader never I've never seen it no I
know but that's why the story right like
if he wants to do the hero's journey
here it's like man do it no I know I
know it's crazy I know it's crazy but
it's worth getting more people to talk
about it for the next two weeks because
otherwise he's going to announce and
they are gonna have to battle it out I
would say this DeSantis will be by far
if if he wants to run I don't know if he
wants to run I know him decently well
now I was I was alive
my show from the victory thing I mean
the guy he's surrounded by incredible
people he's competent he's decent he's
clearly a good husband he's a good
father it's like it's not going to get
better than this I don't worship
politicians I don't no it is not going
to get better than this guy and I would
say the real question for those of us
that live in uh in Florida and I really
honestly can't believe that you live in
California Ricky um is do we want him to
run you know I think there's an argument
to just keep him here and let's keep
this place as strong as it can be and
you know I think I think that's worth
thinking about to the opening the
opening where you have an opening to
capitalize he's
yeah he's never been better no I mean
okay so okay so 62 out of 67. what's he
gonna do better four years from now well
like what's gonna be better than today
you know everybody won in your state you
flip the purple into red
are you gonna be able to Peak that it's
kind of like you know you're wanting to
get a contract with a team and you want
to sign a 10-year you know half a
billion dollar contract like you do you
are with baseball no I'm gonna I'm gonna
play one more you're on a one-year
contract and I'll renegotiate my no no
no no no go like this year right now
yeah Aaron judge judge it how many home
runs last year 62 yeah so he broke he
broke the record around now where's the
time to renegotiate your 10-year
contract he's probably gonna end up
going to the Giants based on what Tom is
saying but he he needs to now get his
half a billion Auto contract what do you
think what would you make of it if he
just was like I I don't want to do it
like I love this state I love what I'm
doing I love everything that I can
accomplish here and I think that the
machine is so easy if he said that yeah
I don't think yeah I don't think he's
that guy yeah I think he's a guy that is
a leader amongst leaders I think he's a
guy that it has had his uh I set on
leading for a long time so he was a
teenager I don't think this I think this
this guy was a teenager you would have
known something was different about him
I think if he was 22 years old you're at
a bar having a drink with him and
talking to him his language you're gonna
know this is not a regular guy if you're
watching a football game with him you're
like this guy's gonna do something I
don't know what it's going to be and
he's done it you know being a commander
and being a commander of a Navy SEAL
unit to go on and being Congress six
districts Daytona to go being a governor
you would only buy 34 000 votes and then
it's Landslide 40 to 60 Charlie Chris
and then everybody in your State wins
because of you and then you flip a
purple to a red this is it so if he's
ever gonna run this is your opening if
he's not now here's the part if he does
if he does run
now my concern if I'm him is the
following because this is also what you
don't want it's the replacement game my
entire mindset would be if I'm him it's
who am I replacing because if you are
going to go be the president and if you
are a king maker who's the next person
that you're working or developing or
thinking to say here's a five or six or
seven candidates that would make a hell
of a governor in the State of Florida
let's start kind of shaping their
mindset of course some people gonna come
from the outside I think that's what I
would be thinking about if I'm him it's
probably on my top 10 list right now to
find my replacement if I run for
president if I'm not planning on running
for president ever
uh then you don't need to think about
that because you have plenty of time
they've got to be thinking about it one
way or another and again I have no
insight into I know his people pretty
well I have no insight into whether he
wants to do it or not but they have to
be thinking about that but I'll tell you
a great story about uh him and running
and how huge this victory was so when we
finished up my book tour the last stop
that we did was in Orlando and I had
DeSantis as my special guest so we went
right into Disney and and did this show
there and they had protesters and
they're screaming and all the usual
nonsense but I'm sitting in the green
room with the governor Just the Two of
Us for about 10 minutes before the show
and we're just mostly want to talk about
baseball actually we're just kind of
yeah like it wasn't about politics he's
just a decent dude and uh and I said to
him I said uh you know Governor you're
going to win this thing by 15 points he
laughed in my face he said six or seven
six or seven and now he won by 20. I
mean think about that he thought six or
seven he said six or seven and that
would be huge and the guy won by 20. do
you think that do you think that he said
that because he didn't really how much
of an impact he had made
I mean so look it was not was he not
aware of how much people really
appreciated what he was doing and how
the rest of the world does he not view
himself the way we've we view him in
order for him I mean I've had dinner
with him a few times he's he's a he's
normal he would sit here with but does
it make it sense what I'm asking like
yeah like does he not see what we see
but that's great though it's hard
that might be the ultimate secretly
didn't want to get too cocky like of
course I got that's what I think he
wants to be level-headed and just be
like moderate and just be like listen
keep my head down and work my ass off
hold on the reason I asked that is
because if he doesn't there's there's
like you know all the guys here we're
not where we're at right now because
we're not competent we're very secure
but it doesn't mean it doesn't mean you
can't be humble at the same time but the
reason I asked that my concern is that
does he not see himself like if he says
something like that okay then if you
really believe that then you don't you
think that you may not be able to be
president I think it might you can't win
the present it might be something like
this I think you know as someone that
just got here right right that is so
proud to be here and so vested in not
only continuing this place but making
sure that it lasts for a long time I
came in with so much energy and and I
see now so many I'm sure you guys all
see it with new neighbors and everything
else these people that come in and we're
like holy we fled we fled we're refugees
it's amazing
I just have my one suitcase and you know
and uh and I think maybe what he didn't
see that he probably now after 20-point
win sees is that all of the people that
came here not only I mean they all voted
for him everyone voted for him but then
every it was just working here and you
take it for granted when it's working so
then all of these new people come in and
they're so excited about it and I think
maybe the he couldn't quite quantify
what that excitement was you know
because for him it was like we're gonna
stay open we're supposed to stay open
I'm not gonna put you out of a job
you're not supposed to be out of a job
I'm gonna send your kid to school so I
think maybe there was a little bit of a
a disconnect but to your point I think
that might be the beauty of the whole
thing of course I I 100 agree with you I
was just wondering you know because I
want him to believe that and I'm sure he
does I mean he has the right people
around him too like hey run for
president because that's you're gonna
win one question so Dave so him so Trump
Trump's saying that the sanctimonious
statement that you know they call him
that name uh because desantas didn't
come back or no
do you guys think because of that one
thing that one moment a two questions is
he is it is it over or do you think
there's people like in Trump's team like
Yo dude chill out he's the future kind
of make amends because this guy he could
bring you when you guys would be the
perfect team to then bring you the
santis with let's say you know I'm just
being whatever Carrie Lake and then Lake
can run when she has her time and she
can pick Tulsi gabbard two females you
know running you know like what do you
got my guess my guess is if Trump has
good people around him and it's always
that's always the thing with him like
are they good people are they actually
there to help Trump or are they there to
help themselves or whatever it is if if
he has good people around on him I would
imagine that they're sitting around
Mar-A-Lago right now going okay so if
DeSantis runs and if you run what is the
move on him how do you take this guy out
you can't just oh I have rumors about
him and whatever imagine them on a
debate stage where Trump's trying to
call him names or do all the tricks by
the way I don't have a major problem
with the tricks the tricks got him
somewhere there's reasons that they're
not great too but if they were on a
debate stage and DeSantis just every
whatever the thing whatever the garbage
was that Trump was throwing at him if if
DeSantis just kept saying this is what I
did in the state this is what I intend
to do these are the numbers this is the
support like there's a real defense
there without having to play the game
everyone else tried to play the game
against Trump remember when he was going
after Little Marco Rubio and then there
were those two days where Marco tried
and it's like you can't beat Trump at
his own game but maybe the way you beat
Trump and again I say this as someone
that likes him so that's the weird part
but maybe the way you beat him you beat
him through pure competency and DC
and just not playing and yeah well
what's the famous phrase like uh Never
Wrestle with the pig because you both
get dirty and the Pig loves it and
that's Trump he loves that so as someone
who's been lifelong Floridian this is
would be my advice to DeSantis real
quick so
um you know this is the famous saying
man plans God laughs okay so kovid was
desantis's moment to shine while the
rest of the crazies were locking down
and masking up and vaccin up he's like
not here in Florida like unless there's
another Black Swan event that was his
moment Carpe Diem right and the last
thing is
you never like Dave we started the show
with me saying hey welcome to Florida
these hurricanes happen like get used to
yeah we're gonna have another five years
of hurricane season God forbid three
years from now there's another Hurricane
Andrew and he doesn't run for president
this time around and Florida gets
devastated he's at an A-Plus ranking
right now you can't get higher than
where he is right now he thought he was
gonna win by six or seven you thought
15. it's 20 brother yeah you could only
go down from here
whether it's floor you know some
situation in Florida situation you know
federally in the overall Union now's
your moment and whether or not you have
to take on Trump or not you have to
seize the moment because you do not know
what's going to happen five years from
now isn't it not at all isn't it crazy
that there's so many people in this
country that don't want what we have
here that they either just don't get it
or they don't understand how good it is
or whatever but like when I was driving
back from Tampa yesterday so it's about
a four and a half hour drive to get back
to Miami I just kept thinking the entire
time man the night did not go great the
way I suspected but I am so happy to be
here I I did the thing you know you can
all you can always talk about what
you're gonna do or whatever but I left a
place that was crumbling I moved two
companies here I moved an awful lot of
people here everybody is freaking
thriving and happy and it's going well
it's great and it's like that's what
it's all about so you still have that
chance in America where most countries
you don't you know if you don't like
Trudeau in Canada whether you live in
Calgary or Toronto
yeah that's it you got Trudeau great
Point Dave I wish you would have kept
our little secret down here in Florida a
little bit before everybody
Brent's gone up 40 bro there's some
stuff
in it so Adam look at the license plates
it's not a secret but you know what it
is though people people have a hard time
detaching from their abusers of course
you're right yeah right that's what it
comes down to I mean it's as crazy as
that sounds it's the reality Behind
these people have a hard time detaching
from their abusers so I kind of want to
leave California no honestly you know
what's funny you know here's here's the
crazy part I was literally just having
this conversation with a friend
yesterday that that I'm I'm very
attached to my family so is my wife my
grandparents are there they're the only
two that I have left left were very
tight-knit extremely tight-knit so to me
it's like okay do I sit there at my
income do I pay the you know crazy ass
state taxes and enjoy my family the time
that I have them like especially more my
grandparents than anybody else or do I
move not I get to see them as much and
how do you go back to their funeral
because that's kind of where we're at
and I said no I'm gonna stick around for
a little bit longer until you know my
grandpa's already 80 something years old
he has heart problems my grandma's you
know a little bit healthier but she's
not all great so I I had to put things
in a balance because you know I've been
talking to Pat about it like I wanted to
go to Texas I love Florida but um I just
needed to put these on a balance it just
you know it's well everywhere everyone
has that negotiation because I tweeted
this out yesterday about federalism and
that if you if you are not happy right
now if you're in Pennsylvania and you're
not happy you can move and then of
course in Twitter where you get only the
best of the best it's gotten a little
bit better something's going on with
Elon something's happening there you
know I saw the main the main comment I
got well it's not easy to move that was
the main thing that I got and it's like
well okay but in life nothing worthwhile
is easy it's not easy whether you have
you know I'm obviously doing all right I
had two companies that I was moving it
wasn't easy to move my life it wasn't
easy to get all my guys to join me and
move operations and all that but I could
get you might have nothing it would not
not be easy to move you might have all
sorts of family considerations and all
those things but
at least you've got the freaking Choice
yes for now for now yeah so you know
being Middle Eastern a lot of your
friends are Middle Eastern they can't
leave because you have to leave Auntie
Uncle Grandma so I'm the Hispanics
Middle Eastern we're very close but
going back to the Trump and uh DeSantis
concept so you know you talked about hey
you know you're going to win by 15. I
think six or seven right he wins by 20.
20. what are you talking about his
speech he was on fire yeah he said look
I just want to say when I first won I
won and many of you didn't vote for me
the first time those of you who have now
voted for me I want to tell you thank
you for trusting me to vote me in right
I mean there's an emotional connection
now with Miami-Dade yeah he's talking
about them to support you so so I think
that the difference is
desantis's personality doesn't allow for
blind spots everybody has them no matter
how paranoid you are you have blind
spots Trump's personality creates many
blind spots and the tough part is you
know I I don't know if Trump's asking
what do you think like okay so I don't
know if Melania is talking to him late
at night I don't know if ivanka's
talking to him I don't know if junior is
definitely not going to be saying hey
you know I think it's DeSantis he would
never ever say that it's kind of like
Junior telling his father Gotti Hey Dad
I think it's time for somebody else to
be it's just not going to happen that
mindset's not going to be there however
you know everybody thinks they know
uh how Trump thinks everybody thinks
they understand this guy everyone's like
oh let me here's what I would do if I
was Trump you
you haven't been in before 77 years you
don't know what his mom told him when he
was 12 years old son never let anybody
you don't know what his dad told him
when he was eight years old and for him
to throw in the towel as a method of
being disloyal to his parents you don't
know we don't talk about those
conversations privately those are very
emotional and his loyalty is not to his
wife
I'm not talking in a marriage sense I'm
talking in a vision sense his loyalty is
not to his kids his loyalty is not to
the Republican party I feel his loyalty
is to that eight-year-old kid that 14
year old Trump who had a conversation
with a grandpa or Fred or his older
brother who became an alcoholic or
whoever it is I feel if there's anyone
he talks to privately when he's praying
or he's talking to God or he's doing
anything I think he's talking to his
parents he's talking to his you know hey
Mom what do you think I should do hey
Dad what do you think I think those are
the types of conversation as weird as it
sounds I don't think he's calling
regular people saying what do you think
we should be doing now I did talk to
Giuliani when we were at his house and
we were doing the interview for Mafia
States of America which by the way today
Rolling Stones did an article on these
oh yeah yeah it's it's enrollment by the
way I think it's the one year
anniversary coming up right now it could
be yeah it could be but yeah you're
right
we're sitting there with Rudy and you
know we talked Trump and Rudy says that
you know him and Trump had a
conversation and he says look if I if
you notice I'm being unhealthy and I
can't talk I'm not the same communicator
and I'm sounding like Biden tell me to
stop I'll stop that's what Rudy said
that's what Rudy said to you to me that
that him and he doesn't know you
meaning like you're not a confidant with
him no no Rudy said to me that Trump
told them
he's telling you this yeah by the way if
I start battling tell me Trump told wow
said to Rudy hey so here's you know so I
think I don't see Rudy you know it was a
three and a half hour interview it's a
four-hour interview we sat there in his
living room we're done this is by the
way this is this is a week after they
took the stuff out of his uh FBI came in
so it's like at the time when this was
taking place and uh so if he says that
to Rudy that means there's a few people
that yeah maybe there's a few people
there but here's the other thing that we
have to we can't forget I I think you
know I've been running a sales
organization for 21 years
the mistake I made early on as in my 20s
and my early 30s I picked my killers and
my rabbits too early
just because I like their personality or
I like how they were or I liked and I'm
like yeah but that guy's too quiet
yeah but that guy is not as fired up as
yeah but that guy's a better speaker
than this guy there was a guy named Jose
Jose was a quiet guy
nobody backed on Jose when I first
started my insurance company crazy story
September 23rd I had 52 agents that were
working with me directly
I told him I said guys you can pick and
choose these seven people you can work
with okay these seven people choose to
work with any of these seven people you
get to pick and choose and come and tell
me because now that I'm running a
company I can't be working with you guys
directly I have to do operations
there's this guy named Jose okay and his
wife Marlene do you know how many people
picked him zero do you know today his
business his agency does 40 to 50
million a year more than anybody that
was in that room and more than anybody
that's ever been with us so meaning you
can't pick your rabbit's tour you can't
pick a person saying this is a long race
A lot can happen the next year and a
half we don't know what's going to be
taking place we don't know what's going
to happen to Arizona if Kerry Lake wins
Arizona okay and let's just say Nevada
what's the guy's last name Alexa let's
say he wins it let's say you know he was
desantis's roommate in college did he
did not know that really yeah very
interesting yeah so if he win if they
win 51 5149 Senate say that happens it's
not likely it's going to happen well
let's just say it does happen Walker
wins you know the runoff in December
let's say Nevada wins and let's say
carry Lake wins Trump can't say I had a
victory so you know there is that part
where he can say carries my person Kerry
said my favorite person in the world my
second favorite person in the world is
my husband my first favorite person you
saw what you said and she's a very much
of a if if Trump is here DeSantis has
seen in the way they handle issues
they're both direct I think Kerry's here
yeah I don't think she's here I don't
think she's here I think she's here
she'll call people out so it's still too
early you know the season you know you
everybody is about you know in NFL they
say who's going to win the Super Bowl
whoever stays healthy when the playoffs
start the playoffs hasn't started yet
for presidency you don't know what issue
is going to come out with the sentence
you don't know what's going to come out
with bite you don't know what's going to
come out with Newsome you don't know
what's going to come out with Trump
trump we still have a lot of time you
know what's going to take place don't
forget also Trump loves to to surprise
people right so the only reality show I
ever watched in my life was the
Celebrity Apprentice I've never seen any
other this was before Trump obviously it
was politics and president and all that
for some reason I watched that show I
have never I never I can't even think of
any other reasons I never saw I've
literally
got no idea what they're doing
but for some reason I watched that and
on that show the the Mastery of that
show and they tried to replicate it with
Schwarzenegger and they couldn't they
tried it with Martha Stewart and they
couldn't was that he would every week
he'd do something nuts that you thought
he couldn't do so you know they'd have
four people remaining and suddenly he'd
fire three of them out of nowhere and
just announce the winner you know so
there is that's why I think this I uh
he's having this conversation publicly
teasing out Trump you have some options
here to make you still be a winner you
can be a winner here and not be the
president of the United States you can
have the rallies have the love get all
the support and and actually maybe not
have to do all the stuff that that
actually DeSantis is quite good at yeah
here's where I feel pretty good here's
where I fully agree with you and then
also maybe where I disagree the craziest
reality show I've ever seen and I've
literally been on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians for an entire season okay I
did not know that okay
the craziest reality show I've ever seen
is a second debate where he brings out
it was Keeping Up with the clintons we
brought off of Clinton's yeah Mistresses
on a debate stage was the most insane
I'm like this guy just brought out
Clinton the hookers yeah to a
presidential debate how is this even a
thing and that's that's Trump that's
right here's the one thing I'll say
about Trump but this is why I do not
think he's gonna by the way he said
hookers I don't think these girls were
hookers they were just people that he
yeah because you can't say hookers
so here's the beautiful thing about
Trump and this is not a knock on Trump
this is actually the truth I actually
believe whatever he says I take it face
value meaning I don't think he has a
hidden agenda I think Trump literally
says what he thinks good or bad whatever
he says I'm like that's how Trump thinks
you might agree with it you might
disagree with it he's not like alrighty
I said that on TV but behind closed
doors I'm doing this I think he's just
like Russia if you're listening like he
just says [ __ ] so back to the
sanctimonious thing if you want to just
get a little insight to what he's
thinking
it's the exact same Playbook 2016. look
at the poll numbers 80 want me look at
the sanctimonious he's a 10 good job
there Ron well you know the ground the
crowd wasn't into it oh I agree I'm not
saying that the crowd's not into it I'm
just saying he's doing it so I'm taking
what he does at face value oh Mike Pence
at seven percent better than I thought
there Mike all right buddy uh what's her
face uh Liz Cheney three percent yeah no
wait she's got three percent no he's
that's how he thinks so he still
believes that he has 80 percent uh
approval ratings within the Republican
party and if he actually sees that he's
not going anywhere is any kind of funny
it sounds like we all just want him to
be a little bit better we're not asking
for like major re-haul with him right
like it was just like could you just be
a little bit better for this moment
perhaps but a leopard cannot change its
spots and Trump ain't doing it it's 78
years old look I say one thing though
let's not forget that this dude came in
even like came in and everybody came
against him the Mead like he up he hit
the Beehive he got stung by everybody
the media and it was all set up it was
all [ __ ] Russia was [ __ ] all
what kind of attitude would you have if
you're a boss yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you came in and you know what you
said your fake news and because of that
look at CNN it's gotten the [ __ ] because
he pointed them out all those all the
Pelosi all the everybody came on him bro
he fought back I wouldn't trust anybody
and I'd be an [ __ ] if I was him too
so what do you expect I don't agree with
the going after uh the Santas but bro
it's a fight if you're number one you
want to be number one you're talking
[ __ ] and the gloves come off I get that
you know remember when people would
always say you know I like I actually do
like Trump but the twins the tweets are
a bit much and I always thought that was
such a bizarre thing to say because it's
like oh so if the guy who did the thing
that nobody said could be done would
just behave a little bit more like you
who've never accomplished anything
then you know so that's why it just
always
funny uh Dave that that's that's the
issue that's Adam's problem
that Adam cannot see Trump's
accomplishments because he doesn't like
the guy
100 sure
that was not a question that was a
statement I don't know if you know the
difference
no because you don't like him apart from
others accomplishments lowest
unemployment in history for blacks and
Hispanics highest stock market uh uh uh
first president to ever walk in North
Korea and meet with the president North
Korea lower the textures with Russia win
a trade Wars with China
bro the list goes on and you're still
like oh you know [ __ ] this guy I'm like
bro come there's gonna be a I don't like
him I don't like them is a lot of his
personality either but at the end I want
to live in a country where my taxes are
low stock market's doing good
unemployment's low and we're beating
other countries and that's what Trump
gave us so all this other [ __ ]
there's a bunch of emotional [ __ ] of
people that don't like how he is that's
why he's a winner you're not going to
like winners Michael Jordan you you have
Scottie Pippen talking [ __ ] about
Michael Jordan on on the this show
um what what the the Last Dance The Last
Dance all of a sudden he's a Michael
Jordan's an [ __ ] dude there was if
you read the book and you when you talk
about when you talk about Michael Jordan
all the guys that left his team after he
left were getting big ass contracts and
then we're not worth that because
Michael Jordan was no longer around so
that's what I'm getting at like no
matter how much you don't like a person
if they're making everybody better and
they're making everybody's lives better
financially economically socially
whatever the case may be the how with
how they act oh it's not very
presidential every other president's
screwing you over so what the [ __ ] what
the hell does it matter I talk [ __ ] but
give me a good economy talk [ __ ] but
lower unemployment talk [ __ ] but lower
uh Texas with Russia and talk ship and
win trade trade you can't have it both
and the the thing about the a lot of
Americans is they want both you can't
have it both either you're gonna have a
good speaking guy like Obama
is an idiot or and with the country and
then the Hispanics love them in 2014 he
created the cages our people are in and
deported more people more immigrants
than any other person in history but he
speaks well like you gotta choose one or
the other you can't have it you can't
have your cake India too that's and
going back to your point that's that's
you described Adam you know Point by
point on that's that's that's the this
is the American people right here like
well here great job Ricky uh how do you
really feel you're reimbursement
that [ __ ] was not rehearsed
over well here's what I will say I'm
actually one of the few people that will
acknowledge his accomplishments and say
I do approve of what he did was able to
when I'm in office oh yeah let me speak
and then I'll come to you that's how
this works
I will acknowledge what he did for the
economy I would he would acknowledge
what he did for unemployment I will
acknowledge what he did for the stock
market I will acknowledge what he did in
the Middle East I'm able to do that but
it's not about me I'm letting you know
I'm giving you insight to what 50 plus
percent of the country thinks
and 50 of the country like for instance
if I hear Nails on a chalkboard
I don't care what you're writing on the
chalkboard all I'm hearing is ah and I'm
like no that's good for you bro it's
like the American people this isn't me
Ricky this isn't you the American people
hear him speak and it's Nails on a
chalkboard and then you have people like
you that's saying no what he's writing
on the chalkboard is good and people are
like yeah I just don't want that sound
in my life and here's my point do you
think most people not you not me not
Dave not Pat not Vinnie do most people
vote because of policy or personality no
personality okay so you know the answer
yeah so people don't like his
personality so don't be shocked when he
doesn't want well I I would also add to
that that if you think about it this way
can Trump bring in any new voters is
there anyone that didn't vote for him
last time that suddenly couldn't make
sense
I would say there might be some really
broken Democrats who are just like Biden
as dementia this thing's going to [ __ ]
and maybe so you get this tiny amount
the bigger issue though is that the
amount of people who will be depressed
by the end of four years of Biden that
will suddenly vote because they hate
Trump you probably increase that by
about 5 Vote or something like that so
that's the problem Trump has he doesn't
have his ceiling is basically there
already but the floor now moves because
a certain amount of people hate him that
that in some ways is the best argument
for DeSantis it's like DeSantis actually
can bring in a whole bunch of the
disaffected Liberals and the
Libertarians and blah blah blah and the
hatred of DeSantis although the media
will do all their tricks and they'll
make him what they're going to do I mean
I've been saying this for a year he'll
be he'll be Hitler but worse because
he'll be competent Hitler right Trump
trump was incompetent Hitler but they'll
make him competent Hitler that will be
the argument that he's functional but
has all the bad ideas and Trump was just
a buffoon but that's the issue is that
DeSantis can bring in a whole bunch of
new people who who's the new people that
Trump can bring in that that's a real
issue I'll ask you one question and this
is my entire point of where I stand
politically because I don't know I'm not
on team red I'm not on team Blue I'm on
red white and blue I love America I'm a
very moderate person in all aspects of
my life who has a better chance
of getting to a 60 approval rating
Donald Trump or Ron DeSantis yeah who is
it no it's DeSantis it's not even close
yeah and that's what I want for America
I want whoever it is whoever it is the
president to be a unifier and Donald
Trump as love him or hate him he will
get you 45 no problem you know I've been
you ain't getting higher than that I've
been playing a lot of old Reagan Clips
on my show from before before from the
60s before he was even just as he was
becoming a politician before he was
governor of Cali and then as president
and it's like that aspirational message
it's the same stuff that DeSantis is
doing DeSantis has to push a little more
against the woke stuff which Reagan was
doing more directly towards Socialism or
communism right but it's the same
message of this country is good let's
get the government out of the way live
your life like it's basic stuff that we
all want but yes we still have this
issue where a certain amount of people
they J they don't know what they want or
why they should want it and we that we
just have to either accept or or figure
out how you deal with it did you hear
what the Santa said about uh Florida
well this is where woke comes to die
yeah I love it yeah it's a great line
right and what I like about the sand and
I voted for DeSantis I see what's going
on Florida I think he has the ability
all I'm looking for is the ability to
get to 60 because that's my One Wish For
America we're not enemies like Ricky and
I like like can we get to a point where
we're just like yo you're cool homie we
might disagree but we're good we may
never get there I mean look we have a
federalist system for a reason and the
states may just kind of go their
separate ways and that you want to
neuter the federal government as much as
possible that might be a much better way
to deal with all of this like at the end
of the day it's it's sad right I'm from
I'm from New York I lived in Cali it's
not you don't think that it should be
that way we're supposed to be the United
States but maybe at the end of the day
the only way to do this is we will just
continue to do it right here and we will
take the refugees and then hopefully
make sure that the refugees know why
they came here but if but Cali is gone
it's just gone they just re-elected
Gavin Newsom even worse than that
Michigan Gretchen Whitmer oh my God
Gretchen Whitmer was evil I mean purely
evil her intentions are evil that's what
I mean they don't know the intentions
she's evil she was Banning people from
planting seeds in their Gardens during
covid I literally sent from crazy Cali
yeah I was sending people planks and and
seeds she's evil and they decided yeah
we would like more of that the people of
New York hochul literally said during
the debate I would do it all over again
mandates and all that and then these
morons voted for her so at some point
it's like well what do you want me to do
I live in Florida I live around freedom
and good people well Dave New York
they're
we can talk about all day about New York
how liberal they are but Michigan let's
talk about Rust Belt I mean they voted
for Bush then they voted for Obama I'm
talking to Michigan yeah and then they
voted for Obama then they voted for
Trump and then they wanted Bernie but
then now they got Biden Michigan is a
you talk about a flip-flopper every four
years they're going a different way my
dad's from Detroit so my my I asked my
grandma my grandma voted for Bush
she did not vote she voted for McCain
she voted for Trump she could not vote
for Trump again she voted for Biden like
my grandma is from Michigan and she like
you're talking about someone who voted
Republican but would it would go either
way she's like I just can't do this guy
yeah there's two things around him
that's what's happening there's two
things there first of all you cannot
take an election result in America and
and interpret that as a mandate and
here's why because you know the
pollsters are usually wrong but usually
where they start and they start with
okay some basic numbers in a particular
State let's take a state say States 43
you know registered Democrat that they
think are pretty locked in and they look
at history in the state and maybe 40
Republican so that's 83. they put on
that about 15 points of legitimate
modern day independent voters and then
about five to six percent depending on
the state for libertarian in green
that's the playing field the billions
are usually spent on that 4 14 10 to 14
in the middle and as you look at these
where we're locked in we are locked in
in America right now it's it's kind of
like looking at Coke and Pepsi if you do
case studies on market share of soda
through through the 80s they would spend
billions on advertising and they were
both locked in at 44 market share you
know and it was and and Pepsi went to
the Fountain business and tried to get
the fast food and do it that way the
point is you can't take these elections
and interpret it as a mandate Michigan
didn't flip-flop as much as the
independent voters were moving and Trump
knew that when he did those rallies in
the rural areas he's like I can't be 65
out here out here I got to be 75 because
it's got to counteract core Detroit
that's going to be voting how it's
locked in and that's the first point and
so I think we have to look at the
billions spent for the 15 in the middle
usually now if if you look at a unifier
a true unifier in DeSantis you now see
that the only way he gets to 20 points
is that Florida broke not like so many
other states and races so many races
went exactly the way I'm describing here
but Florida a bunch of Democrats walked
across the line you know and he didn't
get 100 of the Republican vote he got
pretty close to it and The Independents
came across the lie because there was
two things he was a unifier and he got
the job done covet I think my Governor
got the job done you take a look at what
happened with with hurricane Ian and he
was over there in those white boots for
a week not doing a photo op dropping in
he was at the command center he had
National Guard guys over there he had
these things and people look at it hey I
think my Governor just did a pretty damn
good job
DeSantis went from 35 000 vote Victory
when elected initially to this because
he did a great job and it took stones
and it Cooks standing up and then being
right in those moments where he stood up
and the people of Florida have said you
know what you know I I'm with it and I'm
with it to the point you're making time
what's the point you're making you're
saying there's a drink Coke not Pepsi
there's two is one is the elections you
can't look at it as a mandate because
you have to look at these tight
statistical you know results that we
have and the second is we need a unifier
that is a true unifier and somebody that
gets a job done that's not just throwing
out you know oh hate the other side
because of this hate the other side
trying to move people on emotion yeah
and you
you personally is that what you're
saying uh DeSantis is it's not true I'll
vote for it's who's earning it and I
think Governor DeSantis has earned my
vote and earned my support he's doing a
great job in the state where I live you
know something something else happened
in Florida that I don't think people
realize how important it is in terms of
getting guys like you and the
disaffected Liberals which is that 15
right if there's 15 if that's the number
we're going with that can move it's like
how do you get those guys to move you
guys may remember I mean nobody really
talked about it in the media but
sometime in March or so we Florida
passed the 15-week ban on abortion 15
weeks is three and a half months
regardless of what any of our personal
beliefs are in terms of when Life Starts
and all of those things that is not only
what I would consider the moderate
position my personal belief might be a
little bit before that actually but not
only is that the moderate position it's
the position that every sane Democrat
had 20 years ago no no there was
literally literally no Democrat that had
eight months post-burst birth abortions
which now is the movement in the
Democrat Party that is Cali that is New
York these are laws that they've passed
he got helped by that because they're
going now they're going uh uh two weeks
after birth no post birth
but but the fact that that's not how
moderate about that no well that's the
point so that that's the point so
Florida is actually probably the most
moderate State on abortion so you can
think of now you know the media will now
paint Florida as this crazy far right
conservative red blah blah blah but it's
like actually what are we we're moderate
that's the truth so so what what makes
it easy for media today to go after
Trump is if Lake loses if Herschel
Walker loses and if Nevada loses they
can say whatever they want to say I will
tell you if Lake if Walker and Nevada
win they don't have a lot to say to
Trump okay does
so meaning if that does take place yeah
forget about it right so Trump's back a
month from now saying I told you I told
you and he's going to play that card
right man it's tight Pat look at it yeah
no no I I I oh my God yeah but they're
saying they could be counting all the
way into Thanksgiving if not Christmas
they said they said they're prepared to
work until Christmas I want to know your
opinion on that like we were talking
right before we walked in in the 1800s
during a Civil War people voted and in
one week they had the results we are the
most technologically advanced we have we
have [ __ ] on Mars walking around right
now we can't count the vote and it's not
going to come out I gotta tell you guys
it was so yesterday obviously or two
days ago was my first time voting as a
Floridian it was such a freaking
pleasure I go to this school Pleasant
people there dressed in normal clothes
didn't look like a homeless shelter you
go in they hand you a piece of paper and
a pen you actually do it yourself you
then put it in an envelope you walk over
to a booth where there's someone
standing they confirm that you are you
after you've already shown an ID you
drop it in you feel like oh this process
is not pure nonsense there's something
actually happening here right versus
Cali which I voted in many times where I
literally the last time I tried to vote
in the recall election where I
campaigned with Larry Elder awesome did
not go well but I tried
um I actually busted out my ID it was I
wasn't even thinking about it I was just
like oh I'm showing up at a polling
place you show your ID the woman freaked
out she kind of likes racist it's racist
to show your ID what yeah is she weird
it got weirded out yeah they don't I
don't want an ID he's got a gun I'm a
polar yeah come on and and you have no
faith in the system so the fact that I
did something where you then have faith
in the system and there's even even
Chris and and whatever crazy Democrat
messages exist here in Florida nobody's
nobody's claiming there's fraud here
there is nobody claiming there's fun
everyone and that's why at Rubio's
debate when they asked they asked him in
val demings will you respect the results
and Rubio goes well I'm going to win but
obviously I'll respect the results we've
cleaned up the roles everything is legit
here the and that's what people want
basic confidence
couple things couple before we
transition to the next topic so why do
you think the market tanked 633
yesterday Tom why do you think the
market Tank's 633 yesterday the stock
market hates uncertainty and there is a
tremendous amount of automated trading
and the automated Traders you know that
they plug things into these into their
models based making like a weather
forecast they look at interest rates
they look at employment they look at
Supply costs and they plug those in and
there's oh and when there's uncertainty
you can almost see when all these
algorithms and the programmatic trading
refreshes it was up 300 in the morning
the more remember and the more it went
all of a sudden it starts tipping and
it's because there they look at momentum
they look at a lot of things the market
hates uncertainty and the market says we
have we are not certain about how we're
going to be governed and legislated and
more regulated is the way the businesses
pronounce it we don't know what's going
to happen there because we don't know
the outcome of these elections here here
and here and when they plug that
uncertainty in there what happens is
they sell current positions and what did
you see what's going on today with the
stock market yeah I'm sending that Adam
just showed it to me
850. yeah so basically you're up to 880
in the market today yep everything's up
big big big Dow Jones up 800 S P up 156
NASDAQ Russell ethereum Amazon Tesla
Disney Nvidia Apple meta go everything
up big big big big big big big big the
only thing that's down today the only
thing what what Bitcoin how weird is
that yep so Pat was right Pat yesterday
we should have bought as much [ __ ] as we
could yesterday was the day yeah but
when it was down you know I rang the
bell at NASDAQ since I last saw oh wow
I've had it how was that I've had a good
year
it was incredible it was this was about
a month and a half ago I went to New
York and so locals which was my tech
company that I started to fight big Tech
we merged with Rumble Rumble through
SPAC it was basically the only spack of
the year that actually did the thing as
it was supposed to and uh yeah about a
month and a half ago I went there dang
sick rang the bell and what was super
cool about it was I used to do stand-up
at a little comedy club that we started
it was underneath TGI Fridays in New
York 49th and uh Broadway which was
right next to Lehman Brothers which then
obviously became Barclays and whatever
else it is now uh but I used to stand
out there two hours a night six nights a
week handing out tickets to comedy shows
when I had no freaking money I was
barking I I was broke I was broke I had
a friend who worked in Food Service who
used to just deliver me giant industrial
cans of tuna that's what I lived on for
like 10 years probably gonna die of
mercury poisoning but you look red but
you're rich right now but uh but
literally two blocks away from that I'm
ringing the bell 15 years later that's
the American dream yeah you were super
liberal eating that tuna at that point
now I was I was a lib I was eating a lot
of tuna by the way
I was talking about right talking about
spax uh truth social the day he
announced he's gonna be announcing his
presidency next week
stock went up 66 in a day then right
after super Tuesday midterms uh his
stock dropped 28 okay 22 to 28 the
following days so his thing is yesterday
yeah so yes so so he checked to see
where it's at today the SPAC but it went
66 when he announced that he's
announcing it's because you know how
Trump does that he announces to announce
to announce so he's uh but yeah his back
uh had a good day and then it had a bad
day after the turnout so so town now
that the Market's up 88 what the hell is
going on now well you'll see decent
Cycles sometimes this is called a dead
cat bounce in uh Trader parlance So
Yesterday things go down and then
there's a perception that things are on
sale and so now you add a lot of
momentum right out of the gate making a
purchase I don't think it'll stay this
800 for the to the end of the day I
think it's going to settle back but this
is this is our stock market it gets
spooked one day and then things are down
enough and it says hmm I think some of
these things may be you know what I can
make a little I can make a little play
here and
people you said they said if the the
inflation is going to come at 7.9 if it
comes at seven point and not 7.9 they're
not worried that Powell's gonna
overreact it's still going to increase
interest rates in December but not
dramatically but if inflation comes
eight or higher he may increase by a
point by one basis point in December and
a lot of people are panicking
specifically in the real estate World
half a point is seems to be locked in
right now well here's breaking news from
Wall Street Journal this is 10 minutes
ago inflation eased to 7.7 in October as
underlying price increases including
excluding energy and food slowed down
from four decade High well guess what
yesterday things were down appeared like
they're on sale now they get
confirmation that they're probably not
going to get that one point it'll be the
half a point that they've already got
Market reacts up it has certainty that
it's going to be a half Point not a full
point because that
I just want you guys to know during this
whole this conversation I have nothing
just know about that I want the viewers
to know me nodding you're amazing
like this the one part of this entire
show that you've 100 identify with was
Dave I mean no they're doing the
stand-up Yeah we actually did the same
so I'm from Yonkers New York yeah uh
went to LA stand up and everything like
God bless and I I appreciate Pat every
single day because I contacted Pat and
I'm here now which it was quick I wanted
to ask this early just really fast Pat
what what do you think because you said
it earlier the side that's just like die
hard they're the leftists the Democrats
what do you what do you think there is
it that that side is just so hardcore
they'll never admit fault because I'm I
don't I don't really have a side day but
like when Trump says stupid stuff like
that I go I go dude he's messing up I'm
in nine different group chats that are
all political and I can't leave because
one of them has a freaking Android they
still to this day bro they won't admit I
will I'll never hear you know what
Biden's messing up or this is they're
just do you think is it they just I love
this I think the machine and the mass
brainwashing is so intense that they
cannot get out of it it's that moment so
when I did Mars podcast a couple weeks I
really want to talk about and I said to
him you know he kept saying well Trump's
an election denier and I said well you
know Hillary Clinton did call Trump an
illegitimate president she tweeted it
it's on video many times he was like his
response to me was no that never
happened and he kind of screamed it as
if I completely made it up and then once
I calmly explained no it did happen I
didn't have Wi-Fi so I couldn't show it
at the moment but I've we've been
tweeting about it he had now we've ever
even texting he now acknowledges it's
real but what it showed me was wow even
Bill Maher right this is the gold
standard for liberalism in America for
20 years the left now hates him because
he's an actual liberal right and
unfortunately you know the day before
the election he's on MSNBC he's
basically saying you have to vote
Democrat so I I guess I guess my my job
did not I did not actually complete my
job but I tried I tried I think I tried
more than probably anyone has directly
to his face on camera uh but but that
moment where he where I'm telling him
what is obvious what is you know the
Stacey Abrams election denial all of
this stuff and and that he did not know
I think that's what you're talking about
so then you tell people basic truths and
it is so out of whack with what they
believe because they watch MSNBC and I
mean not that anyone's even watching it
but the culture the culture stuff that
leaks through to people
and that's why they've been censoring us
for so long right that's why this Elon
Musk thing is so massive because I don't
know if you guys noticed this but even
even I think it started this morning on
Twitter if you look at your your
verified you're verified if you look at
your verified mentions now because
people can buy in because of blue bunch
of new ones you don't recognize they're
not verifying right so on one hand it's
kind of like all right maybe I don't
want to see all these people but on
another hand what is it doing it's
making it so that all of the political
journalists and Daily Beast journalists
all of these people who got the blue
check because they work at these places
so you somehow think oh they must be
legit and important well now they're
just like everybody else and and that
hopefully will cause some of the change
here where the guys that you're in the
group with will somehow some level of
reality will crash into them because the
censorship at least at the Twitter level
maybe is you know crumbling did you see
did you see the question that they asked
uh Biden yesterday about musk did you
see that question oh yeah can you post
it can you put it up real quick very
interesting watch this here this year
Elon Musk is a threat to U.S national
security and should the U.S and with the
tools you have investigate his joint
acquisition of Twitter with foreign
governments which include the Saudis
look how long this takes
I think that
wasn't three months
he's thinking
look cooperation and or
look wait wait
wait
technical
relationships with other countries
uh
is worthy of being looked at
whether or not he is doing anything
inappropriate I'm not suggesting that
I'm suggesting that it works worse being
looked at and uh
um and uh oh my God
what a vile statement it's worth being
looked at I'm not saying he's doing
anything but we're going to look yeah
we're gonna freaking look we're gonna
keep look also he has no idea what he's
talking about his people have been the
ones for the last two years we now know
it all those docs that were leaked that
intercept covered we know that the
government was coordinating with big
Tech to silence people it is the it is
the greatest mass violation of the first
amendment in the history of America and
I don't even know did they even cover it
on CNN I actually checked the day the
story broke it was not on CNN's front
page but you know what was uh The Oath
Keepers which is some Trump related
something the day of January 6 the the
Insurrection they spent 400 at Olive
Garden that was what that was on the
front page of CNN that's unbelievable
the day that they break these ducks
that's what we're up against they do
give free breadsticks no I mean so it
seems like it's a lot of money
but here's my question with that because
that's I mean whether you're left right
center up down purple that's not good
like that you can't look at him and be
like that's my guy and I'm not
but here's my point you'd rather have
Biden office at the very least than
Kamala right I mean you came from
California because if you're suggesting
let's get rid of Biden let's get him out
of there let's impeach him let's use the
whatever Amendment together
then you get Kamala no it's all bad I
don't want that it's all bad and these
people will never stop that's what's the
most disappointed but who would you
rather have Biden or Kamala I don't
think it matters yeah it don't matter
neither one of them
has a little bit honestly my theory my
theory on Kamala is that her speech
writers are actually working for us
because that's coming out of her mouth
you know I did a sketch on value team in
college where where I'm tripping up
because we can't find the speech and I'm
like it's outside the writers when we
walk in a room and it's pets and
everybody throwing [ __ ] all over the
place time yeah time the passage of time
but I don't unders we had this
conversation the other day about Elon
Musk and I was like what's with this
hatred of Elon Musk I know I don't get
it I mean checked his Q score right what
were the results of that Q score just
it's the media it's the politicians it's
bureaucracy but the people love Elon
Musk he's about to with the exception of
Dogecoin whatever he's enabling equal
time and he's destroying one of the
pillars of speech control that was in
front of them and they had them all
lined up meta
let me just read a couple things get
them all set and so here's two stories
one not just job Cuts Elon Musk
eliminated Twitter days of rest and work
from home policies last week pushing a
24 7 work culture if you're a Twitter
employee who has a satisfying work
balance life work life balance you may
not want to hear what the new boss has
to say musk cut close to 3 700 jobs at
Twitter or half of the workforce via
email last week musk has also removed
Twitter's days of rest monthly days off
for employees to rest and recharge and
it's pushed to implement 24 7 word
culture additionally Bloomberg reported
that musk plans to end the company's
remote work policy and ask remaining
employees to work to return to office
full-time fantastic now watch this next
one here after weeks of media teeth
Nation over musk takeover Twitter sees
explosive user engagement Twitter's
daily user growth hit an all-time high
during the first full week of Elon Musk
owning the platform according to a
company document obtained by The Verge
since musk's dramatic takeover Twitter's
monetizable daily user growth has
accelerated more than 20 percent while
Twitter's largest market the US has
grown even more quickly per the FAQ
Twitter has added more than 15 million
more than 15 million monetizable daily
user not Bots crossing the court of a
billion marks since the end of second
quarter when it stopped reporting
financials as public as a public company
so on one end they're bashing the guy on
the other end it's getting more
engagement than ever before look the
fact that he is just doing this blue
thing for eight bucks it's like look how
many people are doing it I don't know
what the numbers are on that yet but
people wanted to give Twitter money and
Twitter had no mechanism to do it I
think Twitter is going to look
completely 180 different in a year from
now than it looks right now it's going
to look much more like WeChat which is a
Chinese app which there's all sorts of
reasons that we shouldn't be cloning
Chinese apps but that you're going to be
able to do much more within Twitter in
terms of purchases and communities and
all sorts of stuff that's obviously the
route that he's going but he has
unlocked something he has unlocked the
fact that the government was in on it
with the previous guys and Jack Dorsey
should be hauled in front of Congress
again and again I know nothing ever
comes of it when they do it of course
but Jack Dorsey has a lot to pay for
they still have to expose what really
happened with the laptop and who fully
decided all of this stuff and was was a
call put in by the government to Vijaya
Agate who is the head of trust and
safety and they there's so much that he
can expose right now and covet and all
and hence why Joe Biden is up there
going real well we'll find out and also
don't think don't forget one thing with
with the eight dollars and how he's
trying to monetize he's realizing he
can't just rely on corporate advertisers
yeah to continue you know operating how
they have been because how many
advertisers have already pulled out of
Twitter No someone like 50 has this is
definitely your guys Department more
than mine but has anyone ever bought a
company at the premium that he bought a
company at and then within two weeks
fired 75 of the workforce like is that
is there any comparable to that anywhere
past that normal
it happens all the time with smaller
companies but not at bigger companies
some would you agree with that not at
this time buying buying something at a
premium and then doing something like
this that's not usually the way it works
the way it works is you know it's 1995
and you buy Harley Davidson when it's
really having a tough run but it's a
beautiful brand and it's got products
that can be revived then you remove half
of the people and you restructure it and
then you take off again because it's
Harley Davidson that happened to
Harley-Davidson a couple times in cycle
but it's never a premium where you pay
like this this huge premium for it and
say okay I'm gonna do this now sometimes
you know private Equity will buy
companies like this and then what
they'll do is they'll see they went in
and it's a good sector with good growth
and great fundamentals of the company
and they believe that that you know a
seven percent five percent layoff is
going to increase the profitability of
the company because they believe they're
going to run it a little bit better than
the the previous administration did but
I've never seen something that this
level of Premium that's your first level
of departure regarding that so like if
you're using the Harley David example I
assume that they're firing because they
want to restructure and just kind of
like reposition the workforce
yeah I think this company's not doing
well for a reason and I'm about to fix
it exactly meaning it's not ideological
at all it's actual business but I guess
first impression would be musk is firing
these people a lot of it is because
ideological reasons right I mean is that
that's the premise that I would kind of
obviously there's restructuring and
reformatting in business but is some of
this ideological reasons like we saw
what percentage of Silicon Valley and
those types of companies donate to D's
versus ours I'm wondering how much of
this restructuring firing all that is
business versus ideological I would say
yes but no yes there is ideological
elements here but the other side of it
he's buying this because he thinks he
can do something with it you know let's
not forget this is not George Soros
buying a company and doing it this is an
operator an entrepreneur oh you're gonna
make rockets go to Mars well he's almost
there you know uh oh oh you're you're
going to do the same with the electric
car he's got Battery Technology he's got
electric cars that look good that run
good they're reliable I mean he's
pulling it off so is he making changes
that have ideological elements to it
sure but I think he looks inside and
says wow there needs to be free speech
there needs to be this this needs to be
so much better and I can make a buck on
it and these sons of [ __ ] aren't
doing it so I'm gonna get I'm gonna make
a wholesale change but I think at the
core
some people see ideological you know you
know wholesale layoffs on that no I
think he's looking you Knuckleheads are
doing a bad job you're doing a really
bad job and I'm gonna buy this I'm gonna
do a better job I think I think a couple
times not to cut you off I think a
couple of times like people came in like
and they're like coming in he's like did
you ever talk [ __ ] about me and they're
like no they just pulled up their tweet
yeah you're out that's what I'm saying
like you probably you're probably right
about me you're out okay number 67 out
68
but also also try to imagine what so
many of these employees were doing on
the DL like now that now that we have
some insight and this is what he really
has to expose if he wants to clean it up
and then and then move the company
forward it's like how many of those
employees were reading your DMs because
there's no doubt that they were 100
there's just no doubt that they were how
many of them were making sure that for
example in July of 2021 when I tweeted
out that mandates were coming and
vaccines weren't working and I got
suspended on Twitter was that either the
government that did it or was it an
Insider a Twitter that did it he can now
figure this all out they have logs of
all of this stuff this is not you know
they can't paper shred all of this so
it's like if he just goes in and figures
out who did what when did they do it and
get rid of everybody I mean everybody
there do not hire because of equity
higher because of Competency and and
give everybody what they want it's it's
all it he has it in some ways it's a
very easy job because everyone wants him
to succeed except except for like what
you said there don't do not hire because
of equity higher because of Competency
and that's a major theme in America
today right it's very bizarre I don't
hire people based on the color of their
skin I like what he said uh yesterday he
says please note that Twitter will do
lots of dumb things in coming months we
will keep that what works and change
what doesn't so he's testing right yeah
here's what we're trying what do you
think about this what do you think about
that what do you think about this what
do you think about that and people are
uh adjusting to it and he's going to
constantly figure out a way to make it
better Dorsey yesterday uh apologize did
you see the doors apology yesterday
Dorsey did you read the dorsey's apology
it rings very Hollow to me you when you
had a chance dude you did everything
wrong then you step away also The Dorsey
thing and I've chatted with him
privately a couple times the The Dorsey
thing seems very odd to me because you
guys all know how hard it is to run one
company so now you're running Twitter
like the most public company in the
history of the world where everything is
happening and he was also running what
was the other company he was the CEO of
Stripes
how is that even possible and then and
then you know he goes in front of
Congress and he lies at you shadow man
no and it's like come on man but they
know that nothing ever happens with
these things so you know he's just
trying to get back in I don't blame him
for what he's doing he's trying to
figure out a way to wiggle himself back
in and that that's what any of us would
do right you know if you did everything
wrong all the way well Dorsey must look
at Elon after you know dorsey's running
two companies look at Elon he's running
Tesla and SpaceX and neural link and uh
supports the satellite company
starlink and now it's Tesla it's like
this guy might be an alien he's an alien
at him I like what he's doing I like
what he's doing Dave did you see about a
week and a half ago where he actually he
actually uh tweeted uh two images from
emails between the two Executives oh
yeah yeah and so he's putting it out
there so it's like okay
I'll tell you what for all you guys want
to be yelling about this
here
because he walked in and he said you
know what can you pull the executive
emails here and here for the guys that
just let go don't touch them just pull
them out there I want to see this
dialogue oh this is very interesting and
so he showed America he showed us this
and I think that's uh that's a sign of
what he's saying it is also kind of
funny that a guy who's literally sending
us to Mars decides to get into this
fight of all fights which is the most
painstaking you know just the craziest
cultural fight you could possibly ever
get in and then he fires these guys and
now you know the lawsuits are going to
be endless right because he's trying to
stop their golden parachutes because
he's firing them for incompetency
they're going to obviously claim that
they were not like he's just opened
himself up to everything this guy who
could literally leave Earth have no
problem that any of us could ever
imagine he loves it yeah he loves it
what do you think is his actual
motivation because prior to Twitter I
don't think he was a big
the First Amendment Free Speech got like
that was in his fight whatsoever it was
you know Star Trek Vibes Third Dimension
another world let's go to space all that
now what do you think is motivation I
don't think that it wasn't his mo pre
covet I just think it wasn't as bizarre
as a god during nobody was like what the
hell is going on here and he says look
I'm gonna buy one of these companies you
know I'm gonna buy uh Twitter you know
of course we'd love for him to buy
Facebook and some of these other guys I
don't think he can go raise that kind of
money yet uh in the valley unless if the
valuation goes lower but I think he has
one other play he's got to do I really
think he's got one other play he's got a
major newspaper and he's got to finalize
CNN six billion dollars okay go buy
cnn6play you scare the [ __ ] out of
everybody there if he pass on now what
happens is now he owns one of the
virtual governments which is Twitter and
if he goes buys one of the mainstream
the ultimate mainstream fake news you
know he buys CNN do you realize this is
the one way to actually get these people
to go to Canada this would be the
ultimate way to get people to say you
know what I'm finally doing it I'm
leaving that's it send them to Canada
who's going on trance shows yeah by the
way they don't just let you into Canada
it's not as easy as it is coming here
you know what I mean we're gonna vote
for Trudeau maybe this clown that you
have to do stand up has he ever actually
expressed interest in buying CNN or a
mainstream Legacy Media outlet has he
ever said anything about that I don't
know if he said that but I think Elon if
Elon bought CNN matter of fact I'm on
Twitter while we're talking right now
Hey listen what are you up to tonight I
should go buy CNN what's this guy Dave
I'll just tweet out rumor I heard Elon
it's like the it's like the Larry
Ellison tweet hey um I'm gonna buy
Twitter you know do you want in did you
see that tweet I didn't see that well it
was a DM back and forth and Ellison says
sure and he said um how much would you
be in Ellison responds a billion and he
it's I just find I found that really
out of left field what a random thing
but what a beautiful thing for a person
to have like is he gonna jump on any
movement any company hitting like this
something must have really hit him where
he's like I'm gonna spend all this money
I'm Gonna Change I'm gonna make a profit
at some point but I want the truth to be
able to be said well to Patrick's Point
that's what's so cool about post covid
is that it woke up so many people to
some level of reality some level of red
building Elon this is obviously not the
direction he was going to go in as he's
building Rockets right and and doing
everything he's doing with Tesla and
literally underground tunnels and all of
this stuff but then something happened
along the way where he was like you know
what enough's enough well it's that line
from Homer Simpson I'm a guy like me
like someone has to do it I'm a guy like
me I guess I'd better be like this the
Tipping Point I'm obviously don't know
his mindset The Tipping Point was when
he was like all right I gotta move Tesla
I gotta move to Texas oh maybe that's
then he moved to Texas it's a shame he
didn't move here I know yeah you
remember what the Tipping Point was
Twitter right he was the Babylon b band
remember the Babylon B got banned of all
places the B got banned and Elon Musk
said you know what I think I'm gonna go
by Twitter this is ridiculous yeah it's
actually true what was beautiful about
that too was it was played out in real
life I mean he was on the Babylon B
podcast either that day or the next day
like he obviously planned they weren't
planning on getting man he then saw a
problem and then he just shows up at
their offices I I've been there I mean
they've got very Rinky Dink this is not
a fancy operation and he just starts
talking and then next thing you know
it's like oh other people kind of
believe the same things I believe and
are are sick of the lies and here we are
you know eight months later and the guy
owns the freaking don't forget and by
the way this is ridiculous whatever this
guy is I'm gonna go back and see if he
ever lied about it
was such a hack oh god really yeah don't
forget Elon Musk is from
South Africa so he grew up with
apartheid he understood he's an African
American exactly you're right exactly
so thank you
just then he's amazing but so like in
his core DNA obviously you know he's
dreaming space and all that in his core
DNA he knows what Injustice really looks
like what it really looks like yeah and
obviously Nelson Mandela I'm assuming
had a massive influence on him and you
just I'm just speculating here but after
being raised in South Africa apartheid
you must have some sort of like this is
what Injustice is this is what freedom
is this is what's right this is what's
wrong and everything that happened
during Cove it must have triggered
everything he learned when he was a kid
because that's not what he stood for for
that I think that's also right it's cool
that the the billionaire class seems to
be getting involved in the game you know
it's like it's very easy people are
always like ah you know when you have Fu
money you'll do all these things and
then no one ever does it because then
you've got all these companies and all
these properties and all these people
that you're in charge of and no one ever
does it but the fact that teal went out
on the line to support Carrie and Blake
and he got JD in and we'll see what
happens with the other ones uh but he's
out there doing it now Elon I mean they
were the guys that created PayPal
together uh David sacks who is the CFO
of PayPal who's probably worth hundreds
of millions he's advising Elon now over
there so like there's a group of people
that suddenly realized hey we have
everything but we still have something
to lose and they're in they're in and
they're trying to fix it now and we need
we need them that's that's the bizarre
thing the billionaire class is always
painted as evil but thankfully they're
getting involved now so do you think we
were having this conversation yesterday
about Citizens United and you know big
money in politics so are you in favor of
politicians being able to lobbyists and
big money getting in because for every
Peter Thiel there's a George Soros
remember George Soros there's a Koch
brother and like so it kind of goes down
yeah it is a slippery slope I'd rather
have that level of competition just
exist and you just figure out better
ways to get the message across than just
limiting what people can actually do but
you could argue it either way I think
yeah but but by the way to to everybody
there's a competition who's the
competition to musk on the left is it
Bezos
well they're a competitor somehow
somehow nobody has a problem with Bezos
owning The Washington Post and putting
out that garbage all day long right
nobody has a problem with that the same
people who were freaking out over Elon
now
yeah and it's is Waffle free no you're
paying no yeah yeah so and and Twitter
offers a lot more than a lot of these
other guys by the way are you following
the the story of Adidas with Yeezy and
uh uh who owns the design who owns all
of it Adidas to sell shoes based on easy
designs follow and break with Kanye
Adidas said it would start selling shoes
based on his designs and a bit to
rebound after scrapping the lucrative
partnership with musician and designer
Kanye West and that spawn won the
company's most successful product lines
Finance Chief harm all my allheimer said
the Sporting Goods giant was assault
owner of all the rights to the existing
products except for the easy name so the
only thing Kanye owns is the name and
that the company intended to make use of
those rights as early as end of next
year he said we own all the IP we own
all the designs we own all the versions
the new colorways so it's rip it's our
product we believe there are interesting
things coming to fruition in 2023 that's
where we're working through so what do
they do here's an idea do you think
Adidas
takes the design and goes and calls I
don't know uh a you know you only have
like 10 people to do Travis Scott do
they call a Jay-Z do they call guys like
that and say hey we want to call it
something else since we own all this
design since our cons you know the
buyers customers love it let's choose
your own name of it easy add to it or
are they just gonna name it an Adidas
brand uh and people are going to buy it
and at the same time what is Kanye gonna
do leaving he can only use the name but
the IP and the shoes designs is not
going to be with them what do you think
is ended up happening here well let's
start Pat let's ask you a question I
mean you're a person of influence
um you're 50 Cent now okay
hey
um question for you how would you like
to be the face of the sneaker brand
50 Cent so you're going to take all the
easy stuff that everybody knows is Kanye
and because he's gone you're just gonna
put like my brand on it uh I don't know
if I'm into that I just can't see
personally and I'm projecting they're
like a little like Miss Cleo here
reading minds but I can't see a real
powerful brand person yeah wanting to
feel like they were the second choice or
the second here I just don't see that I
see I see it's probably going to be
internal branding making Eternal
branding and run like that because I
don't know how I don't know how you
convince somebody that's going to have
enough magnetism with a buying public to
basically be the replacement I actually
fully agree with you and by the way when
I think of hip-hop I think of Tom the
business 100 but I think of gangster rap
but I actually agree with my best friend
Harry
quoting a 1980s MC light over there
Young MC Young MC but this this brand is
so associated with Yeezy that I don't
see another rapper no 50 Cent Travis
Scott Jay-Z whatever Amigos whatever you
want to do they're not just gonna be
like yep [ __ ] on you I got this thing
what about Kim Kardashian
[Music]
okay so go back one more Slide the first
one you had original Oh Google yeah
what's like the classic easy yeah you
see the black and red yeah
in the middle of the two white ones
right there no no to the right right
right right right there how much are
those I pay for 500 bucks from She's but
but I understand they're comfortable but
I I see them on people's feet and I just
don't get it yeah they look ridiculous
no these doesn't look too bad yeah but
that's a cool looking shoe it's like
that I got the one the bottom one green
if you hit that one that's what I rock
bro I don't know Pat have you ever put
those on Pat no I have not but here's a
question this is not me I couldn't wear
stuff yeah yeah but but like what I'm
wearing right now on cloud I could wear
that for the rest of my life I feel
amazing on cloud to me is the most
comfortable shoes in the world tennis
shoes I wear I feel like I have nothing
on actually I don't have on Cloud on
right now [ __ ] what do you have the man
cannot lie no no no today I got cold I
got Kobe's on
baby's gave me this there is that time I
got Kobe's on those are sick but this as
much as I love these shoes it's very
uncomfortable yeah
basketball but I tell you here's the
part though here's a part though
um Adidas underestimated how much they
were going to lose they lost more than
they people underestimated people not as
woke as they thought they were gonna and
by the way I don't buy Adidas tennis
shoes I think people who bought Adidas
tennis shoes many of them it brought an
audience that they didn't have before
100 okay Nike does have an audience that
they have don't get me wrong I think
Steph Curry's but they did this or some
some players some people are with Adidas
but it's not the same so who's more
likely to succeed here here's a question
for you easy is it is it more likely for
Kanye to take the name elsewhere and be
able to create momentum maybe it'll take
him a year two years three years to do
that or is Adidas more likely to use
that design to get back to the numbers
they were doing who's more likely easy
what do you think I'd be easy well do we
know what the numbers are in terms of
what they put in terms of what they put
into it and what they got back out of it
not just how much they were paying him
and one of the most successful we can
pull up the numbers if you want to pull
up it's one of the most successful
selling uh that sounds crazy to me where
are these people wearing these shoes
here's what I'll say about time
everybody wears them yeah everybody
works with it people listen they're
guessing Cali you know don't forget
exactly don't forget where you came from
people why do people listen to Kanye why
I don't but why do you listen to Kanye
because of his music
you know that I actually do not listen
to Kanye at all I do not like his music
well you listen to Mexican trap music I
understand that but when it's not like
you listen to Hip Hop I know but when
I'm trying to get to tell you is I I
started following calling about my Jesus
after I saw what he stood up for and by
the way I'm not the only one my my wife
is on a tennis shoe no she's not a
tennis shoe trip a girl she's a high
heel and and I bought her usually she
loves them she wears them all the time
because of what he stands for some of us
will stand we'll bite you're the
exception no no I don't understand why
you think there's so little of us in
this world I'm just saying thing that
that Kanye who's how about this let's
just keep it simple who's Kanye's base
who is it what do you mean his base like
if there's like Trump has a base it's a
bhaga clearly it's yeah it's just rap
fence okay exactly so you're not you're
an exception you're not the rule that's
his face I 100 agree so his base is
hip-hop rap that Community right okay
that's why they're listening to Kanye
they don't want to hear his gospel music
they're not trying to hear his ideology
they want to hear his music and there's
a whole famous saying like we want the
old Kanye we want the old Kanye because
they want the old [ __ ] Kanye who made
hits and not just does racist
anti-semitic remarks that's not why
people are tuning into Kanye you might
be more in tune with that but that's not
his base are you saying that are you
saying he's making racist anti-semitic
remarks or you're saying that people are
saying that no I am saying he's making
anti-semitic remarks which one I mean
roll the tape Hoss what do you mean
there's no outfit name one
the Jews did this the Jews did this the
Jews did this the anything that you told
me Hollywood the one the controlling is
that a lie certain Jews is it a lie are
they the only people that control my
question is it a lot is it a lot about
this all Mexicans do this all Mexicans
no Mexico he's saying all Jews do this
who runs the most drugs in the world
Mexicans do is that is that a is that a
bad State all Jews
no he did yeah it's a tweet he said I'm
going death Con 3 on the Jews not all
it's a very different thing bro Ricky
you're gonna live no the thing is again
it's like you want to call out
individual did you see the conversation
he had with Lex Friedman yes of course
you did yes so did it resonate at all
with you bro like I said I'm more
appropriate to call out individuals who
did you wrong or groups of people no
individuals individuals okay so then
you're proving my point whether it's
Mexicans or Jews or Muslim Muslims or
Asians like any time you go after groups
okay I'll give an example that's a
problem in in when we buy our jewelry
Hispanics we say we buy it from the
Armenians or we buy it from the uh the
the Armenians or what's other uh
Orthodox Jews probably the Jews yeah and
we're not saying oh I bought it from
John Joseph the Jeweler we're saying we
bought it from the Jews we bought it
from the Armenians it's just a way of
saying no you bought it from that Jewish
guy
we had this conversations
when you have the car who are you like
like uh okay Nelly like you say like you
asked the the the
African-American gang say who you buying
drugs from the Mexicans why do they say
the gangbanger gangbanger Mexicans
that's not what they're saying it's just
a way of saying something and you're not
that doesn't mean it's the whole group
that's just so again I buy it from the
Armenians downtown L.A that's just a way
of saying something it's just language
bro it's not that big of a deal but
there is a difference between Hector
who's buying drugs off the map Mexicans
and that one guy versus Kanye who has a
massive voice and what he's saying and
what he's spewing so by the way I get
what you're saying I'm not denying it
talk your [ __ ] I don't agree that he
should be silenced I'm not but if Brands
want to drop them Balenciaga Adidas
whoever that's their choice I'm not
denying what you're saying bro what I'm
just telling you is don't look you're
looking too much into that because
that's just what we say that's just how
you speak that's that's just language
you're not gonna sit there and let me
make a list of all the [ __ ] people
I'm gonna I'm talking about that's not
how this works bro who you who I [ __ ]
with the Mexicans I forgot the blacks
that's just the way of you talk that's
the way we talk that's just the way
that's lingle that's American lingo you
don't gotta get all crazy about that
[ __ ] it's crazy
you know what I mean so my question
still hasn't been answered so who do you
think's going to be who do you think is
going to have more likelihood of I think
Kanye I think Kanye because like this is
how America Works he for that one week
everybody was like Kanye oh my God he's
in give him six months he'll be right
back bro Americans forget and forgive
some other [ __ ] will come up don't
forget about it he'll he'll he'll get
what I mean he's still alive he's still
on Twitter on Instagram
yeah which he should be I don't not
think he should be silenced and I'm
Jewish
can I tell you a great story about Kanye
so uh I I've only met him once and it
was an accidental meeting right so when
I lived in L.A I was in Encino and I was
going to Equinox one morning and and he
used to go there I'd see him from a
distance every now and again but there
were a lot of guys there were a lot of
ex-athletes that I used to see Kenny
Smith there all the time and Kevin Hart
was all the comedians athletes whatever
and uh one morning I cannot function
without coffee which is why I walked in
here with the coffee because I got here
late and I I don't have coffee in the
morning I cannot think straight I would
look at you and not know your name like
that's the level that is just not right
without coffee anyway somehow I ended up
at the gym I was with a friend and I end
up and I didn't have coffee and I'm
walking in and you know when you have
headphones in when you have earbuds in
you're talking louder than you think
that you're talking yeah so I see Kevin
Hart standing there and I see Kanye
they're a few feet away from each other
and they've got like all their their
guys and I'm not a Kanye I don't I'm not
a rap guy like he didn't you know now
everyone knows who he is or whatever but
I loudly turned to my friend not
realizing how loudly I was saying it and
I look I'm looking at kind of I'm like
probably you know five feet away from
Kanye and I turn to my friend I'm like
isn't that what's his name
I swear to God and he looked at me you
know he does that thing with his mouth
he looked at me like he was about to
freaking kill me and I just I just kept
moving and I walked right interacted I
walked right upstairs that was it but he
gave me the stare at death but because I
honestly couldn't remember who it was
like it could have been P Diddy it could
have been Kanye like it's yeah
I knew he was like
you must have a very unique perspective
on what's going on with Kanye right now
because obviously you're a pro you know
Free Speech guy you're more of a guy
I would agree with what you said he he
can say whatever he wants I don't want
anyone jailed because of speech or
anything like that but every company has
their right to break ties with him if
that's what they see yeah that's America
they they also May realize in the long
term it isn't you know the best example
of this to me would be what happened
with Roseanne Barr during when she said
that uh what was her name uh she said
she was she looked like a monkey and
that's what God yeah yeah yeah now
Roseanne Barr we were friendly for a
while she the idea that she's racist is
insane like that this woman has any
hatred in her heart or whatever okay uh
but putting that aside even she had the
number one show on television remember
they had rebooted remix
Roseanne the Connors it was the number
one show on television it was an offhand
remark that she meant nothing by and
they took her out I even though I was
friendly with her I tweeted out I said
look she's entitled to say what she
wants and ABC is entitled to continue
that relationship or not I think it was
a bad move by ABC it doesn't help with
any healing it makes people hate more
and all that stuff but that's exactly
the situation we're in right now it just
is and it's better than the alternative
what's the alternative that people can
just say stuff and everyone's locked
into maintaining relationships with
everybody you want Choice hang on where
does that line get drawn because all
right so you have Kanye right uh
Balenciaga Cuts ties Adidas Cuts ties
CAA Cuts ties everybody Cuts ties fine
those are his sponsors right but now
Chase has booted him out yeah all your
money or look at Andrew Goldman right
and Andrew Tate lost stripe Uber Discord
uh PayPal every every way to get money
or to make money so the bank the banking
layer I think is a different situation
and there should be some kind of common
carrier stuff there and this is where my
libertarian part of me kind of gets to
the end of the road because you know
look Alex Jones you may not like Alex
Jones but I think we would all agree
he's entitled to have a telephone right
that he should be able to make a a call
and the government shouldn't listen and
he can be a bad dude on the telephone so
no one's for a t stopping Alex Jones
from being on there and I would say
banks have to be somewhat similar to
that this is probably where crypto
ultimately is the answer despite uh you
know yeah and I guess Kyrie Irving
posted something that had some type of
connotation with you know anti-semitic
stuff but they had they they like he had
to go like five different Rehabilitation
meetings no so that that kind of Mafia
stuff like you got to apologize to the
ADL and all that none of that does
anything it doesn't make anyone less
anti-semitic it doesn't it doesn't lower
the temperature it makes everything look
real oh I gave 500 000 yeah exactly you
know like none of that stuff works I
think you you the way things work is you
talk to people you explain why these
ideas are obnoxious and and historically
bad and all those things but the the
bank layer I think is the is the key one
here right like that's honestly if any
of us were all going into business
together that's the thing that you do
and that's a massive risk like father I
don't know you mentioned Andrew Tade
Jake Paul just posted this today if you
want to play this this should be
interesting
apparently him and Jake Paul faced off
I mean that looks serious
who's that guy in the middle he's gonna
do nothing to break this up anyways
if there is a fight that people would
watch they would watch this you know
what fight is going on this weekend it's
gonna be uh Dustin 48 against Michael
Chandler this is the fight oh my God by
the way I thought it would be more Logan
Paul Than Jake Paul I think that's the
fact they actually have beef this feels
staged to me but I think Jake Paul I'm
sorry I think Logan Paul and Tate
genuinely have beef this feels like a
little
concocted would you where is it though
where would this be is that Miami is
this in Europe is this is in the states
whatsoever Tate it'd probably be in
Dubai I got to be honest I'm not an MMA
guy I know everybody that has a podcast
legally you have to be an MMA guy you
have to talk about it like you give me
like Jake the Snake Roberts for Sanjay
the giant I'm very happy
but Jake Paul you can tell you grew up
with 80s wrestling yeah by the way who
wins that fight Tate versus Jake Paul
not Tate you've seen Tate box he's not
dude he's a kickboxer he's slow and his
feet don't move and here's my thing with
all these polls
against the top G bro how are you gonna
do that I respect what's the age
difference here it's like it's like
everybody was so excited when Anderson
Silva got beat I said Anderson Silva's
48 years old
it's a football game
it's not like Tate some old washed up
guy I think he's 36 years old 36 38.
listen respect the Hustle but the the
the the the the craft of box bro these
to me are jokes like you just said he
beat up and yo Silva's 50 years old bro
you're in your 20 like yeah MMA fighter
how about this you know what I would pay
and I would not illegally stream yeah
I'm saying it I if he fights if one of
these guys fights a real MMA guy fight a
real like fight Michael Mike Channel
that's a legitimate by the way at this
point in their careers Tate and Paul who
is more hated
he just got bailed out yesterday yes
because they were not wanting to let him
out they were not wanting to bail out
and he bailed out a million dollar bonds
because after eight months so he he went
after the guy that either molested or
did something to his niece or nephew and
he accidentally shot the driver of the
car that had the guy did the guy die no
he didn't well then then dude he got out
he got out last night so shout out to
Kane Velasquez by the way shout out to
Vinnie this is the first time I've heard
him acknowledge he was willing to pay
for a fight he steals everything Adam
from New York he's in New York from New
York what am I what am I doing over here
hey Tate is in Dubai that was not in
Miami
hey before we wrap up here sign off just
remember about the VPN we discussed
earlier here uh uh that we discussed so
if you are wanting to take advantage of
it have 107 percent increase from last
year so start protecting yourself right
now Pia is having a massive Black Friday
sale for our customers exclusively 83
percent off with four months for free
it's only two dollars and three cents a
month go to
www.piavpn.com forward slash pbd
piavpn.com forward slash pbd to take
advantage of this discount Dave thanks
for coming up man this was fine
tragic what's what do you have on your
agenda right now like what's going on uh
well my Show's normally at 11 A.M so
we're going to 2PM today and then I got
some pre-tape stuff and uh maybe I'll
shoot some hoops tonight I'm playing
again it's very exciting after that
all right we're gonna ball we're gonna I
mean you're going like hardcore like
yeah I wear three freaking braces one
question and I'm playing I'm playing
with a bunch of guys I know you gotta
rap but play a little bit you guys that
it's all middle age so every week
someone's dead
[Laughter]
yeah classic anyways hey have a great
weekend guys before you wrap up I'm
sorry what's that this weekend tomorrow
is Veterans Day thanks yeah I'm doing a
special show today excluding the
veterans in tomorrow and sauce Castle
what do you got on later today a couple
veterans okay one sex expert or used to
be a veteran so we'll keep it sexy with
the veterans but you know thank you for
yourself yes this is you this is you you
guys
oh you forgot about me I'll just give
you a shout out that you're not stealing
anything listen Ricky was a veterano so
Ricky's also
shout out to the veterans out yeah we
appreciate it thank everybody have a
great weekend bye-bye thank you guys